right now it's December 1st I want the  four of us to make our NFL Super Bowl  matchup prediction Chief Eagles very  easy they're to clear our favor I'll  have my life in Philly I'm a Chiefs fan  respect I think the current Super Bowl  is going to be the Cowboys and the  Dolphins that's who I think it's gonna  get hot I'm like man if that's a Super  Bowl talk about two really good fan  bases in the scheme of things I know the  Dolphins don't come out but the Dolphins  have fans there's a lot of 45 to 50 cars  living around the world that like the  Dolphins that's super cool would be  crazy Cowboys haven't been there in a  minute Dolphins haven't been there since  84 I think a real minute and that's what  a my hot my current take is Kayla Eagles  and bills I'm kind of like sort of  almost with you on that but I think  Miami's a little early I'll go bills  Vikings that's my actual great